pftpm from the barn continues now with
jets head coach adam gase like everyone
else been working from home and kind
enough to give us some time in the
aftermath draft coach gays how's it
going good how you doing i'm doing good
what's been the biggest adjustment for
you since the world turned upside down
i just just kind of
same as everybody else contact with
people you know it's just kind of weird
seeing
you know your players over the
over online being online
compared to
you know actually seen in person having
having conversations
you know
face to face
and there's something to be said for the
presence that a coach has in a meeting
room and i i know that's going to be
impossible to duplicate when you're
doing these sessions via video
conference you're one of the teams that
started this week with the virtual
off-season training program how has that
been for you several days in getting the
messages across to these guys when
you're not in a position to physically
grab them by the caller if if needed
it's it's been good i think guys have
been excited to just do something
different
because it's not groundhog day for them
it's you know every day's we're getting
to talk about something else we can
watch different
you know every group is watching
something different you know and aspects
of of film um
it's it's been fun for me because i can
bounce around from meeting room to
meeting room and you know just kind of
see the guys and kind of talk a little
bit and see how everybody's doing and
that's been a fun aspect of it and
you know you feel like you have you
actually have some access you know you
can kind of split up your time offense
defense you know individual meetings you
don't have to everybody's not going all
at once
so i hadn't thought about that you've
got meeting rooms what by position group
and then you can just swoop into any of
them any time you want right we we got a
we got a window where you know these
guys got a couple hours to get get their
meetings done so
you know we we tried to stagger them
because
we had we do have some guys on the west
coast you know majority of our guys are
on the you know on the east coast so
that that kind of helps in certain
positions but you know obviously our
quarterback room we got you know
two out of two out of the three
that are under contractor on the on the
west coast so we're trying to get him up
bright and early i'm sure he's he's
loving that when
you know we try to kick it off right
away when he gets up what time are you
dragging him out of bed uh he he don't
have to start to age so it's not too bad
but if i was if i was 23 years old i'd
probably want to sleep
one of the uh oh trust me i got a 23
year old living with me and the argument
that i get when i say why are you
sleeping until 5 pm the response is
there's no reason to get up
he's right um
the the virtual offseason program for
the jets like plenty of teams no workout
component it seems like maybe six seven
teams are doing the workouts what was
the thought process for not including a
workout we just felt like as an
organization it was the best you know we
we had
a huge discussion about this we were
trying to figure out what was the best
thing for us to do we felt like that was
the best thing for us to do we'd focus
on you know the mental aspect of it we
talked to a lot of guys about
really kind of
you know what they were doing and what
they had access to so we just felt like
you know with so much unknown we felt
like this was the best thing for us to
do
uh let's go back to the draft before we
do that i mean from your perspective
working at home i mean it's one thing to
not have direct access to your players
but there is something to be said
for a little quiet a little solitude
being out of that pace that you can find
yourself in when you're the head coach
when you got people asking you questions
all day long it's hard to get into a
rhythm it's hard to get into a routine i
there has to be some benefit to being
able to
find a quiet spot in your house and just
grind and grind and grind especially
when you're watching film before the
draft or whatever the case may be it was
definitely beneficial
draft wise i think there's you know a
lot of guys you know position coaches
including coordinators and and guys and
personnel were able to
you know whatever they didn't have
finished because i know you know a lot
of guys probably were a little ahead of
schedule and
you know once it kind of everything
starts slowing down and everybody got
shipped out to their houses we were just
all focused on the same thing just
really digging deep into these
you know
the draft stuff and
you know you're right it's really if
you're gonna contact somebody there you
had a good reason to call somebody or
facetime somebody or try to get on a
microsoft teams or zoom
kind of sessions but there had to be
good reason it wasn't just kind of
swinging by you know someone's office
just to sit down and bs for a little bit
like there was a reason behind it so i
think there was a lot of guys that
probably took advantage of that time of
you know uninterrupted work you know
outside of you know if you had kids and
things like that like like i have three
kids you know under 10 so
you know finding quiet time it was some
days were better than others
you know and nobody knows how the world
is going to look and feel when it goes
back to whatever normal is when all of
this ends do you think things that you
learned by necessity through this
process are going to be incorporated in
the way that your team other teams may
do business will it be one day a week
where everybody works from home so they
can
slam the door and focus on their work
and maybe have a zoom meeting in the
middle of the afternoon but otherwise
everybody has a chance to kind of
squirrel away and get work done you know
it's it's interesting because that that
is a conversation that joe and
you know joe douglas and jaime our team
president and myself we've had
conversations about
what can we take out of this you know
that may lend itself to next year and
you know whether it is kind of how we do
some of these interactive meetings we
did with college players we felt like
those were very inter you know
beneficial for us and
well you're at the combine your position
coach is talking to a guy and he talks
to him for 15 minutes and
you know it was just him and the
position coach where the
you know the interviews we were doing
online
with our the players in college you know
with this the internet access was you
would have all your scouts and personnel
guys and coordinators and co there were
so many people were able to listen
to one conversation and it was very
beneficial because we were all getting
that it wasn't hearsay we were all
sitting there listening ourselves and
we're able to ask questions we wanted to
ask
and i do think there is some benefit
that's going to come out of this and
it's just really like we're just trying
to keep good notes and just hey what are
the things that we like how do we think
the draft meetings went you know what
what benefited you know us in that whole
aspect of it there was a lot of good
things that came out of that i mean i
know it's it's great to get guys in
person but to the extent you can cast a
wider net have more people involved save
some money i mean let's face it it's a
lot cheaper when you're not flying guys
in or flying your guys to them there are
some benefits there and i have a feeling
teams are going to look at that and see
how how can we all improve our
procedures in the aftermath of this
event all right let's go to the draft
you were in a spot where you had a high
pick but it was low enough that it had
to drive you crazy because when you're
waiting for 10 other teams to pick i
mean i don't know how much you work
through all the permutations but you got
a lot of different combinations of ways
the names can come off the board how
prepared were you for all the different
ways that those first 10 names could
have been announced and then you figure
out what's going to be left for you
joe did a good job of going through so
many different scenarios whether it be
us sticking at the pick we were at
trading back trading up just any
anything that could come about you know
just
hey what what would we do in this
situation it almost felt like we were
getting ready for a game the situations
that he was kind of thrown at us and and
the kind we were just constantly having
these meetings and he did such a good
job of of just having us ready to go and
then if we were there and and
you know one of the players that we said
hey we're staying here we're not going
to move was there and and we take them
and obviously we were in that position
for us where you know a guy that we were
really fired up about you know
basically coming to 11 to us we were
able to stay there and take the guy we
wanted um i feel like i've been in this
situation a couple times i think almost
three of the five drafts it's been 11 or
13. so i mean you're you feel like
you're in no man's land you know you're
always hoping for you know one of those
guys you know when you have a block of
three or four guys that you think might
come to you you know you're hoping one
of those guys are there
how active were you at potentially
trading up higher to get uh beckton or
whoever else you may have wanted you
know i don't i don't think it was all
there was a whole bunch going on because
i do think we had
you know it was kind of coming to us i
think it was more situationally when we
were talking about it before the draft i
don't i don't remember that really
coming up you know ahead and you know as
the draft was going on plus it was hard
to hear with my kids
we're talking non-stop
my son must ask me 500 times who are we
picking who we pick and i'm like be
quiet i need to listen
so they were in there with you i saw
pictures and images on tv of them but
they were there the whole time uh they
they were popping in quite a bit my my
ten-year-old or my eight-year-old son he
was really active and popping his head
in there to make sure that he he was on
on board with what we were doing you
know i think the the best luck i got was
when when we drafted uh when i said we
just drafted a punter and he looked at
me and he just shook his head and walked
out of the room i was like
hey we we don't have one right now buddy
like we gotta go we gotta get one so
it was uh it was a fun fun fun draft to
be a part of yeah i wonder where he got
that attitude about punters from if
maybe he lives with a head coach who may
have may have said something in the past
i don't i don't remember ever saying
anything here's the thing though because
i was going to ask you this later but i
may as well ask you now
when you use a draft pick on a punter
there are going to be people who say why
the hell would you do that you can get a
punter anywhere they're falling off the
trees
what is it that caused you and and i
know you're working with joe douglas on
this but what caused the jets to
ultimately say we're going to use this
sixth round pick on a punter you know
it's it does get a little competitive
when you if you if you dip in the
college free agency part of that it
starts to get competitive we didn't have
a seventh round draft pick at that time
um
we felt like that was that was a a good
good move for us and and to be able to
to create that competition we needed to
with you know on our roster in that spot
we know that's an important you know
specialists in in our division are very
important obviously new england's done a
really good job of making sure they
always have good specialists whether it
be in you know you know as far as field
goal kicking or punting they're always
causing all kinds of problems and it's
you know you have to make sure in this
division that you do have good
specialists because you're playing in
buffalo you're playing in new england
you're playing in new york and all of a
sudden you're in miami there's there's a
lot of bad weather you got to deal with
and you have to have guys you can rely
on
um
back to bechten
you know it bothered me that uh
word got out of the drug test issue at
the scouting combine we're not supposed
to know about that the teams know about
it from your perspective though
especially with the new cba was that a
factor at all in your assessment of the
player i think we i think we look at
everything you know any kind of
information that we get that that was
the thing i think i was really impressed
with how deep joe
dug into everything with him i mean the
guys that he talked to i mean who knows
how many
coaches that he's talked to i don't know
if he went all the way back to peewee
football or what but i mean he he knew
the ins and outs of of his life it was
really impressive to see how far that he
was digging with those especially those
top guys what is it to get you excited
about beckton as a player
he's a large man and and he is he is
violent he's physical he's nasty and
it's it's everything that you look for
in offensive lineman when you look for a
guy that you know putting on the ground
is not good enough you know just being
around this guy when he watching a room
you feel his presence he's a large man
when he walks in the room he blocks his
son for sure yeah you should have used
uh the sixth round pick not on a punter
but on his dad
i mean this is not a small family yeah
dad dad dad stood out when they cut to
the camera at the bechton household so
you see where makai got it from um let's
move on around two because receiver was
obviously a big need for the jets
denzel mims taking in round two and in a
draft with so many receivers and so many
guys you could have waited to get in
later rounds what was it that that
caused the jets to pull the trigger in
that spot on a receiver yeah i think it
was just it was the right spot you know
we you know we were kind of watching how
everything was moving around and i know
you know joe did a good job of trading
back and creating you know some more
draft capital for us and
you know we were just i'm not sure if we
were really willing to wait much longer
you know we we were we were keeping an
eye on him and and he slid a little bit
and we were fired up when we were able
to pick him i know he he was
i think he was a little surprised he he
lasted that long and you know even us we
you know you're looking at it and you're
not always thinking that you know some
of these talented guys are going to last
as long as they do because you never
everybody's got a different flavor that
they like as far as receivers go and
you know for him to fall fall to us at
that spot you know we were all excited
about it we're fired up to get him in
the building whatever that's going to be
and see how we can help him improve and
you guys were the last team to not draft
a receiver at the top of the process the
raiders took henry ruggs the third right
after you took bechten
how tempting was it
when you have your pick of any receiver
and you clearly have a need with robbie
anderson gone and you're trying to help
sam darnold how tempting is it to not
just say hey we can get any receiver we
want this is our top guy let's go get
him
that's what happens when you got a gm
that's a former offensive lineman
uh we you know we talked about it so
much as as far as and and that you know
we joke about it all the time of how how
i'm always gonna be leaning towards the
skill guys and and him being a former
offensive line and he's always gonna be
leaning towards the bigger guys and or
as he calls them the real skilled guys
so i was uh
you know we we had the discussion way
before we ever got to that point so if
if we did get to that situation where
where it was we're at 11 and beckham was
there and the receivers were still there
we knew who we were gonna pick and
that's we pulled the trigger on the guy
that we knew we were gonna pick how hard
is it though to stick to what you've
previously decided when it's all
happening and you gotta put yourself
it's just like anything else you just
gotta put yourself in the in the mindset
of that hey this is our game plan and
when we decide this is what we're doing
then we're all on board on this
um
the uh safety position was addressed in
round three and of course when i saw
that i thought of jamal adams and no one
can really get a firm grip as to where
things currently stand between the jets
and jamal adams as he enters year four
of his career
what is the current relationship where
where is it right now between the jets
and jamal adams
you know it it's har i'm not involved in
any contract talks which is is kind of
the one nice thing about when
technically you don't you're not 53 and
you can you can kind of you know worry
about your relationship with your
players and focus on those type of
things and you know the front office has
to has to focus on a lot of the contract
issues and things like that and
you know i try to do everything i can to
to to support jamal and then at the same
time you know make sure that i'm doing
everything i can to help joe and the
organization
you know and what they need to get done
as well and and managing this and you
know the big picture of everything so
you know for me it's it's
i haven't i haven't had that discussion
with you all you know it's just
something that you know when it's a time
and place that i need to get involved in
then i'll do everything i can to help
but as of right now you know the
contract stuff it's worse i'm so far
removed from that as at the moment
because i'm focused on the offseason
program quarterback james morgan was a
fascinating pick in round four in part
because he's a guy the patriots were
sniffing around pretty heavily what is
it that stood out to you about him
you know i think he's a guy that has the
the traits that we're always looking for
in a quarterback he has
you know the football kind of the
passion and the hunger for football the
football iq is definitely there you know
it just seemed like it was the right
right guy for us and you know i i
we had those we had multiple
fourth-round picks and kind of the way
it was going he was you know the highest
guy on our board and you know he was a
guy that we were extremely interested in
and when we had the opportunity to take
him that's what we decided to do and i
felt like i was i was excited dow was
excited joe was excited the person oh
guys we're all fired up so
you know he was he just fit what we were
looking for
how hard is it though when you consider
he played at a lower level of
competition how hard is it to take what
he did watch his film
and project how that is going to work
when he's jumping all the way to the nfl
level versus where he was in college
yeah i mean you've seen it before with
with multiple guys that have ended up
being really good players in this league
i think really it's at the end of the
day sometimes the hardest thing is to
project what their mental's going to be
like how are they going to be in the
locker room how are they going to be
seeing things when they change you know
how how do they process things you know
those type of things we've that we felt
really strongly about that
we did we felt really good about a skill
set you know i mean i i get it like
people look at sometimes and say fiu and
they're not really sure and
but you know we feel like his skill set
was exactly what we were looking for and
then his ability to process and learn
and do all those things that you have to
do as a as a quarterback in the nfl we
definitely felt like it was there how
much harder does that become then when
you finally get on the field whenever it
may be if there's no off season program
training camp maybe gets delayed or gets
truncated wherever the case may be how
do you give this guy enough
opportunities to develop to the point
where
it's justified giving him one of the 53
roster spots yeah it's the the toughest
thing right now for really every team
this league is going to be the fact that
we don't have an off season and it's
going to be thrown all of a sudden could
it be training camp or is it going to
even be a shorter time then of just
really trying to evaluate and see where
everybody is but the the thing is is
we're all in the same boat
you know and we just got to find a way
to expedite the process that was one of
the things that i think makes him
extremely valuable is his ability to
process to learn how intelligent he is
his love for the game trying to get
better all the time and you know we get
on the field we got to just kind of see
where we're at at that time and see what
we need to improve and i agree with you
before i let you go this concept of
every team's in the same boat and you're
right the rules are the same for
everyone if one facility is closed
they're all closed no off-season program
for one team no off-season program for
any team but i don't get the impression
anybody really knows where the boat's
going what kind of information are you
getting from the league as to
where this all is leading or are you
just in the same spot i'm in the fans or
in the media's in where we're just like
well we just take it one day at a time
it is groundhog day from that
perspective and we wait for further
instruction as to when in the health
things are going to get started that's
we're all in the same boat we're on the
same boat and
and that's how i've been taking it i
know a lot of people i've been in
contact with they've been taking the
same way is one day at a time
and really that's all we can do right
now if we try to predict what's going to
happen
two weeks from now
i mean you're just
you're creating your own anxiety you're
worrying about things you can't control
because this is this is definitely
something that none of us can control
right now you know we're at the mercy of
really kind of
time and and what we're told we can and
can't do
so i mean we're we're just extremely
focused on just a one day at a time
mentality it's in you know for our
players to to embrace that right now is
gonna hopefully help us in the long run
and you know i haven't thought about
this until just now but from your
perspective look we don't know what what
shape the season's going to take but
it's not unreasonable to assume that the
stadiums will be either empty or
sparsely attended because you can't fill
it up like you ordinarily would how much
are you planning for getting your guys
ready to go out and play before a home
crowd when there is no home crowd
because it's got to be a different
mindset from the standpoint of getting
guys fired up when they know when they
run out that tunnel there's not going to
be anybody there to externally get them
in the right frame of mind to go play
yeah i think like this one is it's it's
hard for me to even think that far ahead
right now
that that is definitely something that
if i get to that point i'm going to be
excited that we're even talking about
that at that point considering
like we were talking before this the
last time i left my house was march 25th
or whatever it's been like i don't i
don't even know like what our days are
anymore you know i'm always asking what
day of the week is it so
if we're talking about that i'll be
excited i will say this
if it does come to a situation where you
don't have fans in the stands or it's
limited amount the good thing is when
you're playing another team
and these guys being the professional
athletes they are you you watch some of
those practices that you you'll see when
that when it's you know the joint
practices it's intense because the these
guys they are professional they are very
prideful
there there is that that team
camaraderie of competition you know
that's real i mean we have to do it a
lot in practice where there's nobody out
there and it's just the coaches and the
players and there's competition there um
at the end of the day though we're so
far from that right now that it's it's
hard to even think about it's really
about hey
what can we do today to get better and
that's what we're doing with those
virtual classroom sessions and then you
know now it's hey let's set up next week
what are we going to do next week that
you know to help our team get better
well we'll let you get back to it coach
enjoy the time with your family and
we'll all keep going forward one day at
a time groundhog day after groundhog day
and daytime
when it's time to play football all
right pal great talking to you good
talking to you
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports